i ragazzi di benvenuto che sono video
sono parigi oggi giochiamo ad una roba
che in un porto da avv
bastarono due anni almeno ed era
veramente figo chiama google friuli e
non so neanche come si pronunci sta roba
evidente quanto scritto qualcosa su
google tipo fa vj che riesce la prima
cosa scritta del suo happy with tu devi
azzeccare l'autocompletamento di google
è veramente figo che giocano lo
portavano un po va promossa allora
vedete che c'è scritto 123 mila e ora 10
devo indovinare le dieci cose che escono
quando la gente cerca è facile far
crescere a child in time sarà un bambino
nessuno gliene frega na sega to grow up
mi hanno azzeccato niente anocro vuol
dire far crescere le o gli ortaggi non i
bambini ma bisogna soffrire l'inglese su
google si rivedevano non sono capace a
20 e divertente essere uno youtuber
demonio italia o una in tutto il video
vi prego
una sola la zebra neanche una incredible
a viggiù ragazzi non hai fatto così
schifo cioè si però non così da luca
ragazzi andiamo sui nomi perché per
l'amor di dio le domande non lo so
ralph lauren e del primo ralph e ralph
breaks the internet con la speciale voce
del vostro amico qui presente break
break a far mulazzo e ralph questi non
li sapevo break the internet cast
[Musica]
andiamo avanti ragazzi con john se non
messina non è al primo posto me ne vado
no ragazzi al nono ma mi vergognate ma
come fate a vivere che trump ha fatto
veramente un casino quando a quando il
presidente funziona nulla
john wayne chiar john week che pirla
john week non è venuto maledizione
ragazzo stupido va bene poi ragazzino su
cultura perché io più vero
il culturame nintendo speriamo le
giraffe sono le giraffe solo alte
no sono animali sono marco demonio sono
reali sono amichevoli
niente monkeys scimmie le scimmie sono
dietro decimi sono smart la terza
perfetto sono chiuse belle carine fa
così schifo umani primati smart fatte di
cioccolato puoi mangiare qualcosa
scaduto quindi puoi mangiare lo yogurt
scaduto perfetto la carne scaduta no
uovo 1 1 allora io la faccio sempre
stato manda 15 st miele
no perché il mio e non a schede sono
stupido e allo yogurt cos'è quella
teaching no perché non si tu non
funziona da voglio ammazzare la società
americana che ignori pizza scaduta o
demonio cibo ramen maionese andate a
cagare tutti quindi ragazzi adesso
passiamo ad un'altra versione un
pochettino diversa che autocomplete che
praticamente tutte vi chi dà già quali
sono le risposte tu devi dire qual è la
prima se ti esce fuori tra queste quindi
posso giocarmi nel senso farmi dire
sarebbe continua ai figli
a farmeli a casa secondo me è la prima
non è vero parameli alle orecchie ok
perfetto
quanto costa comprare una casa una casa
in california
ho un cane o un'amica una casa una casa
puoi incontrare donald trump
spero della prima no posso incontrare
hugh jackman de dolan twins ho sbagliato
tutto
c'è qualcun altro che come me odia
essere incinta amelia shepherd game of
thrones svago o fortnight io credo che
se la giochino tra che motorshow
informatrice keynote rossi vince come
pensate che storia non avrei mai detto
perché il mio braccio
mi fa male dopo che ho sparato senso 3
ma trema
mi fa male in generale l'avrei sbattuto
contro le regole non lo so ho tradito il
mio ragazzo con qualcuno di più grosso
in che senso
allora marco marino se le fa tutte
oppure l'ho tradito con il mio ex marito
con una ragazza
mamma mia per sé difficile con un mio
amico o con lo stesso ragazzo a con un
mio amico con una ragazza
incredibile bellissimo io non so come mi
sentirei si visiti se venissi tradito
dalla mia ragazza con un'altra ragazza
[Applauso]
ecco lo aspetta so come mi sentirei però
diciamo che in quel caso ci potrebbe
essere un modo per farsi perdonare
all'aiuto di entrambe a nyon come
sembrare magri no frega nessuno
bene come sembrare carini no proprio no
carini in un altro modo
ecco prefetto presi e puniti quante
calorie ci sono nella vodka in in un
nuovo le uova sono sempre strada cercato
non è vero in una banana o va bene come
diventare narcisista un santo un membro
dei fatti un giudice fissa
whitewater santino stralessandria belli
siate lo come vedere le foto archiviate
le foto di icloud le password del wifi
dell'iphone vecchi twitter o la scritta
di hollywood
io credo wifi passo con iphone becky
tweet
le foto archiviate icloud ragazzi penso
che però ci sia abbastanza per quanto
possa essere abbastanza google che non
lo sarà mai nel senso che i conti però
giocavano per la vita però quindi che vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa mi piace
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciatela
campanellina che vedete vicino a te
iscriviti e noi come sempre ci vediamo
alla prossima ricerca spero non so di me
bella ragazza
[Musica]